flash floods wreaking havoc on America's
largest city more than a month of rain
falling in just a few hours on Friday
state and local officials urging people
to stay indoors and move to Higher
Ground if possible and I want to say to
all New Yorkers uh this is time for
heightened alertness and Extreme Caution
infrastructure was brought to a near
standstill in this city of more than 8
million people train lines were shut
down major roads submerged I've been
living here all my life and I never ever
saw this ever you never saw this never
I've been here 47 years of my life Liv
here in Brooklyn all my life and this
this is really wow I'm lost I feel
terrible I don't even know where I'm
going because I'm I'm accustomed to
catching particular train now I come the
train is delayed nearly 18 cm of rain
fell on some areas the National Guard
has been deployed
and multiple people have been rescued
from flooded cars and basements the
city's drainage network isn't built for
this amount of water and it's likely
becoming The New Normal this changing
weather pattern is the result of climate
change and the sad reality is our
climate is changing faster than our
infrastructure can respond it's renewing
calls for the city to have better flood
prevention measures you have to prepare
more for the Subways not to be flooded
those are our lifelines I also heard
that 150 schools were flooded I have a
daycare center that had to close because
the drainage outside of it was blocked
states of emergency have been declared
in both New York and neighboring New
Jersey as it stands more than 23 million
Americans are under flood watch and
there's more rain in the forecast
Alexandra buyers Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer